okay so at this point you're probably
familiar with the fish tank cleaner
chloroquine lady the story that you read
and we we talked about this last week it
turns out she didn't drink the fish tank
cleaner because she was a supporter of
Trump
she actually hated Trump we unveiled her
voting records as well as the fact that
she hated her husband was charged with
domestic assault anyway a lot of this
information seemed important to the
story because we were misled and so we
decided to call the original one of the
original code writers at NBC News from
where this story spread to see just how
interested she would be in the facts of
the case and if she had known them in
advance all along or not this is media
today in a nutshell real news let us
know what you think in the comments hi
Erika Edwards steven crowder calling how
are you good thank you so much I'm so
sorry that I missed your call um do you
have a minute well I'm calling because
um I'm actually writing a story here and
I have some some information from an
anonymous source that I want to keep
anonymous and I know that you guys over
there obviously discretion is pretty
important it's regarding the woman who
drank the fishtank cleaner the
chloroquine which I believe I was trying
to find who wrote it I believe you
co-wrote it with Vaughn Hilliard yeah so
right now I'm actually calling from work
yes yes I'm a freelancer and in you know
again I I know I've done some legwork
there and I know it's important to keep
her obviously anonymous I mean I'm
assuming you you know the person in
question who you wrote about sorry I
should ask that first yeah okay
so you did write the story and you are
aware that it's a it's great so I wanted
to ask you this I've come upon some
information you're doing some digging
the story originally that was published
you know stated that she drank fish tank
cleaner and obviously sadly her husband
died and there's an interview that was
posted where she said she did it because
she saw it from a Trump press conference
correct
yeah okay and then she did say that she
trusted him and that no one should
should do the same I have the article up
right here I've wanted to know since you
know were you aware of the fact that she
was a you must be a prolific Democratic
donor very did you you guys you know her
name and obviously it's public record
most people don't have a name because I
understand it's anonymous and rightfully
so
her name but I know you didn't say your
name but I'm just saying I know her name
I was just confirming that way I'm not
letting the cat out of the bag so you
know the woman in question and obviously
you guys do do great journalism there at
NBC News so I wanted to know if if you
had discovered if you came upon this
information er can confirm that she's a
Democratic donor who gave to Hillary in
2016 and repeatedly throughout her yeah
I don't know any I don't know anything
that's not even relevant to the story
quite frankly isn't it relevant because
she said that she did it because Trump
told her to and there are multiple
sources here that show she was violently
anti Trump as an activist for a long
time so it seems peculiar that she would
all of a sudden decide to take medical
advice from Donald Trump when she also
gave to pro science anti right-wing anti
science ideology as it stated here
nonprofits okay mean if you have a
question for me or I mean it sounds like
it's your story well I am asking if you
knew this when you posted the story
because it seems like it would be pretty
relevant know that someone went out
there saying no one should think that
you I think that you have a specific
story that you're trying to tell and
that's totally no see I think that you
did I think that either you didn't do
your due diligence also let me move on
here are you aware about the assault
case with her husband that she mentioned
divorcing her husband because this is a
totally separate instance here we're not
talking about politics but she openly
wanted to divorce her husband and we
found the court documents of her being
charged with assault against her husband
who died from drinking the fish tank
cleaner were you aware of that I think
that you have a store
there that you should go with that
that's not go let me ask since you
published the original story would you
be willing to correct the story since
this is relevant information do you not
see it as relevant information that a
woman who went out saying she did
something because she was a supporter of
Trump when we know that she's not and
she could stand her husband I have the
evidence I can send it to you would that
would that be irrelevant would you like
to care I don't have a big news outlet
that's the thing I have this information
I have corroborated it 100% with
authorities I would love to get it to
you because I would love to see the
truth get out here because as we know as
journalists it's very but it's your
story you can take it I don't I don't
want the credit I just want to make sure
the truth is out there and I can send
you all of this evidence if you would I
think that you have a story to tell and
I wish you good luck I think you have
the truth to tell here and I would like
to provide it to you NBC News
do you understand that this is the
definition of a fake news at this point
I can provide you evidence right now
that she was that's news looking out for
you and we wonder why people don't trust
them these days please do subscribe or
hit the notification bell hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot there are videos
playing in boxes and please do consider
joining mug Club a lot of credit coms
flash mug club where we do actual
journalism never expected to but there's
no one out there doing it